this video is brought to you by
thinkific now over the last decade i
have been involved in selling online
courses in some capacity here at think
media we've actually been selling online
courses for the last seven years uh into
the uh eight figures in online course
sales so when it comes to knowing how to
sell online courses using youtube this
is going to be the right video for you
we have figured out how to use youtube
as our marketing machine so we're
reaching the right people who want to
learn more and grow and who are the
right people for our online courses and
i want to share those tips with you
today now this video is in partnership
with an amazing course platform called
thinkific so if you've not already
created your online course then you
definitely want to check out thinkific
as a place to host your course you don't
want to host it on youtube you actually
want to host your course on a course
platform and thinkific is a great
company for that i'll tell you a little
bit more about them
[Music]
so let's jump into the five tips for
selling your online course using your
youtube channel number one is you want
to make sure you've picked your niche
now i'm assuming that you already have
created your online course and you
already know who your course is for if
you have not done that step then i'm
gonna encourage you to pause this video
and go back to my previous video i did
in this series all about getting your
online course launched meaning how do
you start an online course what steps
should you be taking and i walk you
through that free tutorial so go back to
that video if you've not already done
that but if you're already at the point
that you have an online course so maybe
sales are stagnant maybe you're trying
to figure out how do i match my course
with my youtube channel then tip number
one is you want to make sure that you
are clear on who this is for now i know
you want everyone to buy your thing but
let me tell you if you try and reach
everyone you end up reaching no one
actually i was just talking to a recent
course creator and he said i really
thought that this course was gonna be
for everyone like everyone needs what
i'm selling but after he launched it he
realized that there was a particular
market that needed this course right
there was a particular tribe that needed
this course and so when you are
designing your youtube channel to sell
your course you need to make sure you're
speaking the right language to the right
people so if you have an online course
that is going to be helping people lose
weight let's say you're a fitness
instructor then you want to make sure
that the content you're creating is
actually for those people so don't sell
something that is not in correlation
with what your youtube channel is about
if you are in aviation and you have a
course about actually how to become a
pilot and you're walking people through
that then don't be making food content
on your youtube channel both of those
things need to be aligned in order for
you to grow that business so tip number
one is make sure you're speaking to the
right people in the right niche tip
number two is you're going to want to
create your content roadmap now you
probably have a lot of video ideas but
what i need you to really consider are
what are the 20 questions leading up to
someone purchasing your course you're
not just making content in isolation you
really want to understand what are their
pain points what are they struggling
with what are the obstacles that they
are that are holding them back from them
actually saying yes to buying your thing
so here at think media we are helping
people with our video ranking academy
learn the steps for how to do youtube
right one of the problems they have is
what camera do i use for youtube the
equipment is a blocker it's a obstacle
for them actually getting started on
youtube so we're making content that
then leads them to the opportunity that
we have um after they've decided what
equipment that they should get for
youtube so you need to create your
content roadmap grab a piece of paper
and think about what are the 20
questions that people have you want to
be answering specific questions on your
youtube channel don't just make random
content for random content content sake
actually be thinking about what is the
problem i can solve for the audience
that i want to serve so what are the 20
questions that you have let me know in
the comment section below have you
already done this before have you
created your content map tip number
three is i want to make sure you're
giving clear call to actions in your
videos no one knows you have something
for them unless you tell them you have
something for them so what does this
look like well here at think media if
you've watched several of our videos
even on the podcast you'll hear us
clearly say what we want your next step
to be thank you so much for watching
this video and if you'd like to check
out another video in the youtube made
simple series you can click or tap the
screen right now if you want to learn
how to go deeper and learn the step by
step of how to do youtube right or if
you want to learn the three secrets of
youtube success you can go to our
masterclass which is a free master class
that gives you those tools to get
started now we give you a clear url
which is thinkmasterclass.com
and when you type that in or you click
it in the description box below you are
then sent to a site that you can sign up
for this is outside of youtube and we're
giving you a clear call to action so if
you have a course that you're selling
but you don't tell anyone you're selling
it no one will know that they should buy
it and i understand it can feel weird
but here's the thing to sell
is to serve so when you think about hey
do you want to go to the next step with
me hey would you like to download this
free thing hey would you like to jump on
a free 15-minute call you can do that
here
that is just inviting someone into the
next step in their relationship with you
online that doesn't mean that everyone's
going to take that step and if people
are offended by you saying that here's
what i say
good because they're probably not the
right audience for you you want the
person that needs what you have you want
the person who sees you as the authority
as the expert as the best friend a
couple steps ahead that is telling them
the next step they should go on let me
ask you this have you been sitting
across from a friend before and they're
just really struggling with something
and they say you know what they're
struggling with and you have the answer
for them now if you decided not to tell
them the answer i mean that's on you but
at the same time you have an answer for
them to help them in their journey now i
look at the same thing as selling online
as using youtube as a marketing machine
we have the opportunity for 5 minutes or
10 minutes or 20 minutes or an hour
depending on how long your video is to
give the invitation to go deeper in our
relationship maybe this is right for you
maybe you've been thinking about doing
youtube for the last six months two
years five years but right now is the
right season for you to jump in well if
i didn't tell you that you have a way to
jump in with us to go deeper then you're
probably gonna waste more time more
money more energy trying to figure this
out on your own so
give a clear call to action about where
you want someone to go next here's some
opportunities if you are selling
something that is say over a hundred
dollars or 200
you want to probably give them something
that's an exchange in the relationship
first so what could a free gift be that
you give to someone maybe it's a free
audio download maybe it's a checklist or
it's some way that they can um a
download that can help them get results
in advanced in advance of what heather
in advance of buying something from you
so be thinking about ways that you can
do this you can google this online you
know uh free or
ideas for freemiums or free gifts to
give to people online and you'll get a
bunch of ideas from that and i recommend
thinking about what have you opted into
what are some things that you get for
free online is it a seven day trial of
something is it uh have you gotten on a
call with a real estate agent done a
free call or a consultation be thinking
about the things that you have opted
into because you are part of the tribe
that you're serving so what are some
things that they would want to opt into
as well you need to give that call to
action in your videos and not in a
spammy slimy way you want to offer value
first in your video and then you want to
give someone a clear call to action of
where they should go next all right so
we now know who we're serving we know
the questions are asking we're giving
clear call to actions and tip number
four is you want to direct someone to a
sales page before they purchase your
course so you want to have a sales page
set up not just sending them directly to
your course right not just sending them
directly to a buy button but you want to
give them this page that comes before
the buy button right you want to give
them a page before they enter their
credit card information so here's what a
sales page looks like this is a page
where you are building authority where
you're talking about the features and
benefits where you're sharing with a
future casting of where someone could be
once they've taken your online course
and i'll link down in the description
box below thinkific who is in
partnership for this video they did a
wonderful blog post about the elements
that lead to a great sales page so i'll
link that down below and if you've not
set up a sales page yet and you would
like to do this i highly recommend that
you go with think of it whether you are
a channel about cooking or guitar
teaching or business think if it could
be right for you it can help you set up
these types of pages without wasting
more time and more money and there's
actually a reason why over 50 000 course
creators have already used thinkific to
build their online courses to build
their sales pages and to build their
communities off of youtube
so if you would like to try thinkific
out for free you can go to
createwiththink.com
and get signed up today all right and
tip number five is i want you to build
an email list dun dun dun okay i know it
doesn't sound like a lot of fun you're
like i want to build the next cool tick
tock i want to do the next cool reel i
get it but if you're trying to build a
real sustainable online business or
offline business
you need to be building your email list
now i know that that doesn't like email
is archaic it's not people still
use email and in fact email sales which
is what you're trying to do right you're
trying to sell your course they are on
the rise people
want to have connections in an email
form so here's what i recommend you
doing as you're giving that clear call
to action you want to be exchanging that
free gift
for an email this is gonna help you to
be able to build a relationship with
someone outside of the youtube platform
because here is the reality we don't own
youtube
youtube owns youtube and so we are
building on rented land i need you to be
building on land that you own and so
that means you need to be building your
contact list outside of youtube you
don't own your subscribers you don't own
your views and if it were to go away
tomorrow do you have a way to be
contacting the people that wanted what
you had to offer
without an email list you are building
on rented land and i can tell you about
so many horror stories about youtube
channels being shut down
facebook channels being shut down
instagram handles being shut down and
people's entire businesses evaporating
overnight why because they were just
building on rented land so even if you
are just starting even if you're like
heather i only have 100 subscribers
that's fine
i want you to be giving call to actions
like you have a million subscribers i
want you to be building an email list
one person at a time like you have a
million people on your email list i want
you to be thinking about how do i how do
i engage people on this platform how do
i help them go deeper how can i answer
their questions in email and if you have
questions about building out your email
i'll link to a video down below of you
know places that we recommend and
different softwares that we recommend
for you to have that and if you're
feeling overwhelmed here's the thing
you are building a business so i want
you to take it one step at a time but i
want you to remember that building an
email list should be the foundation for
what you are building upon youtube is
your marketing machine but your email
list is where your customers are going
to come from so i hope that helps you
today get started in creating and
selling your online course and if you
have not yet done your online course
like this is all just ethereal and
you're here trying to figure this whole
thing out you need to watch the next
video where i will be teaching you step
by step for free how to set up your
online course thanks for watching we'll
catch you next time
[Music]